this is the black hole that keeps on
giving it certainly is yes
what's your latest news yeah so you may
remember there was the first ever
picture of a
black hole uh came out in well almost
two years ago now
the event horizon telescope folk have
been beavering away actually with the
same data to
extract even more information from it
and the results of that just came out
just published in
astrophysical journal letters a couple
of days ago it's one of the most massive
black holes we know about so it's about
a billion times the mass of the sun
a really really massive black hole in
the middle of messier 87
in the virgo cluster and it turns out
even though it's not the closest one we
could be looking at
it's it's because it's so massive its
influence is over
as large a region as any other and so
actually it's a really good one to look
at because it's you know it's a
very massive black hole which means its
event horizon is big which means that
even though it's a reasonable distance
away the telescope can still resolve
what's going on
and it seems we've gone from blurry
orangeness
to swirling orangeness
well the the so the swirliness is a
a little bit of a trick in that it's
really just a way of visualizing what's
going on let me show you what they
actually measured
which doesn't look anywhere near as
pretty so here's what they actually
measured
and it's basically instead of just
measuring the brightness
of this ring of light around the black
hole they're measuring this
effect called polarization light is made
up of an electric field and a magnetic
field if you just think about the
electric field
for a moment it's oscillating away
that's what an electromagnetic wave is
it's an oscillation of that electric and
magnetic field
but of course it could oscillate up and
down or left and right and so the
polarization is basically telling you
what direction the light is oscillating
in
and that's essentially what they
measured in this picture is that they
basically measured that
where not only can they tell you how
bright the light is from every point in
in the surroundings of this black hole
but they can tell you what direction
it's polarized in as well
i guess the first thing to say is is
it's it's a complete tour de force of
actually extracting this information
right just making the picture at all was
an amazing thing to do
but now they've gone beyond that to
actually extract this polarization
information remember they were combining
radio telescopes all around the world
and correlating all that data together
to produce this amazing image
and then once they've done all that now
they've got kind of gone back and done
it all again
but but not only are they now measuring
the light but they're actually telling
us
about the way that that light is
polarized and that involves combining
the polarization information that
they've again received from all these
individual
uh radio dishes all around the world so
just getting
a measurement of the effect at all it's
an amazing thing to do but
now that they've measured it they can
actually start learning something about
the process of accretion
onto the black hole the big part of the
reason why we're interested
and why particularly we're interested in
polarization is because
we know that messier 87 this galaxy
produces a jet
flying out from the center which is
clearly associated with the blacks this
black hole
it's a phenomenon we've seen in lots of
other galaxies i think m87 was the first
galaxy it was ever actually seen in
in about 1918 so it's a phenomenon
that's been known about for a very long
time
but we think that the process of
shooting that jet out is something to do
with the magnetic fields that the
magnetic fields are getting all tangled
and twisted up that twisting of the
magnetic field lines is what's
accelerating the particles out to
produce this jet
okay now the nice thing is that the
emission that you see
uh where there are magnetic fields is
this thing called synchrotron emission
where you've got
electrons whizzing around the magnetic
field lines that
emission is polarized and so this
detection of polarization is telling us
something about
the magnetic field structure around the
black hole because the fact that it's
polarized is almost certainly associated
with synchrotron
emission and the direction of the
polarization is telling us something
about the magnetic fields
and the strength of the polarization is
telling us something about the magnetic
fields too is the magnetic field that
appears to be around this black hole
at m87 exactly what we would have
expected has this confirmed what the
theorist said or has it thrown any
curveballs at us
a bit of both actually i mean the fact
that it's there at all is good news
there are two things so the the two
things that kind of come out from this
so there were actually two papers
there's a paper with the observations in
this paper of the theory and the kind of
the things that fed into the theory
paper
from the observation paper are firstly
the directions of the polarization
which is kind of in this sort of the
sort of the polarization is kind of
oriented around
the image rather than radially inwards
or radial outwards it's kind of
curling around the image and the second
is the strength of the of the
polarization
so let's start with the strength of the
polarization it's not actually that
strongly polarized right if you look at
the
scale here the colors here are telling
you the strength of the polarization and
it's like
point you know so they're sort of bluish
in color so it's about a tenth polarized
thing about synchrotron radiation is
it's incredibly strongly polarized it
should be
in a sort of 70 80 polarized and we're
only seeing 10 polarization
probably what's going on there is
there's another piece of physics
a thing called faraday rotation which is
that when polarized light
passes through a plasma and a magnetic
field its polarization gets rotated
around
and so what we think's happening here is
that there's kind of a quite a
complicated
mess of magnetic fields and and plasma
between
us and where the stuff is being emitted
and that is sort of
messing up the polarization so even if
the stuff will very strongly polarize
when it was first produced
some of it gets rotated a bit some of it
gets rotated the other way some of it
doesn't get rotated at all
so the net effect of that is that we
lose a lot of that polarization
information
so this is telling us straight away the
strength of the of the polarization or
the relative actually weakness of the
polarization is telling us that there's
a lot going on
that we haven't yet resolved that's kind
of within what we can see
and the net effect of that is that we
don't see so much polarization
so that's the first half of the story um
the second half of the story
i guess we need to switch to the theory
paper and they did a whole
other a really long complicated paper
where they describe the modeling they've
done to try to reproduce the results
that they
were seeing but interestingly the kind
of the gist of it comes from one of the
first figures in the paper
so this is a figure from the from the
theory paper where they look at what
would happen what you'd expect to see
if you had a toroidal magnetic field
that's a magnetic field which is kind of
going around
and around the black hole the same way
the material is going around the black
hole
a radial magnetic field so that's a
magnetic field sticking in towards the
black hole or radially outwards
from the back hole and a vertical
magnetic field that's one that's
sticking up through this disc of
material that's orbiting around the
black hole
and what you can see is that the one
that really doesn't fit at all is the
toroidal one because the toroidal one
says the polarization should all be
pointing radially inwards or outwards
and yet what we actually saw in the data
is that the polarization is actually
more or less going around
so that's what you expect from the
radial magnetic field or the vertical
magnetic field
and the reason why that's interesting is
that a toroidal magnetic field
is what you'd expect if what was going
on is you've got a whole load of
material that's orbiting around
and it's basically carrying the magnetic
field with it because if it were
carrying the magnetic field with it that
would have the effect of kind of
twisting the magnetic field round and
around and around and you end up with
the magnetic field that
kind of went round and around the black
hole okay and this is saying that's not
what's happening
but the the material can't be carrying
the magnetic field with it
the only time that doesn't happen is if
the magnetic field is so strong that it
actually says no i'm not going that way
and so actually it's strong enough to
actually resist the
the pull of all the material going
around with it um
and that happens when the magnetic field
so mainly it feels weird in that they
actually act a little bit like a gas
they can kind of exert pressure of their
own so magnetic field lines for example
if you think about magnetic fields those
kind of magnetic field lines
they don't get it like getting pushed
very close together and so they actually
use
a pressure back and what this is saying
is that this magnetic field must be so
strong that the pressure terms that just
come from the magnetic field and
itself are strong enough to resist the
gas and not get carried along with the
gas
so that's telling you it's weird the
polarization measurement sort of says
says actually the magnetic fields can't
be we're not seeing that much effect of
a strong magnetic field
because of these weird faraday rotation
effects
but this other piece of evidence is
saying actually the underlying magnetic
field what's producing it in the first
place is very very strong
that was a sort of a toy model just them
looking at what they would expect to see
qualitatively
in the rest of the paper they went in on
in excruciating detail to look at a
whole bunch of detailed simulations
to see if they did and you've got to
feed in magnetic fields
gas physics and general relativity so
they're incredibly complicated
simulations to do
but they basically compared the
observations to a whole bunch of these
simulations which sort of confirms that
qualitative picture and the only things
that they can get to fit
are things that they call mad disks and
a mad disk
is a magnetically arrested disk mad
stands for a magnetically arrested disk
which basically means the magnetic field
is strong enough to stop the disk in its
tracks
and so instead of thinking of the gas
just orbiting around it actually gets
pulled to a halt by the magnetic field
pressure
and will then end up sort of following
the magnetic field and falling into the
black hole rather than just following
a simple orbit around as we'd expect
from a simple disk picture
so that classic animation we always see
of black holes with a kind of
swirling disc around it might not be
what they look like at all
not in this inner part of the disc and
bear in mind they really are very close
to the event horizon the black hole
so probably that picture is right on the
larger scale that there is indeed
material swirling around in something
that looks a bit like a disc
this is saying that actually when you
get right to that final moment
as stuff is arriving at the black hole
the picture must change and the
material probably isn't swirling around
it's being pulled along and along the
magnetic field lines rather than going
around in
nice circular orbits professor what's
actually generating the magnetic field
at a black hole magnetic fields are
everywhere right and
and what probably what's happening is
that what's going on around the black
hole is just concentrating magnetic
fields as you pull the material in
you pull the magnetic fields with it
remember when you're not in this
situation where the magnetic fields
pressure is strong enough to resist this
magnetic fields tend to just follow the
material they get sort of sucked along
with it
so as the material gets pulled towards
the black hole it pulls the magnetic
field with it
and that sort of concentrates the
magnetic field lines so you start from
this very weak magnetic field at large
radii but by the time you're getting
closer to the black hole you can have
quite
intense magnetic fields so the black
hole itself
hasn't got a magnetic field the way that
the earth does or the sun does and like
that
no and in fact it fundamentally can't
because nothing can emerge from a black
hole you can't even have magnetic field
lines emerging from the black hole
itself so it's actually not possible for
the black hole itself to kind of sprout
magnetic field lines this thing called
the no hair theorem right that you can't
actually put hair onto a black hole
and this is the same thing that you
can't have magnetic field lines
sprouting out from a black hole
so the magnetic fields are all outside
the black hole itself and professor that
headline image that we've all seen over
the last couple of days that orangy one
with the cool lines coming out of it
you kind of hinted that maybe that's
sort of his bit of a fudge is it to sort
of
map the data in a pleasing way it's
exactly it's a way of visualizing so as
i say what they actually measured
was was this thing with the with the
little lines and so on
what they've come up with is a really
nice way of visualizing that kind of
swirly effect in interpolating
between the points where they've got
measurements just to give you a way of
kind of visualizing the data in a way
and it's not you know it's not something
that's just being produced for publicity
purposes it's actually when they start
trying to compare
their models with the data that
visualization putting their their models
in the same way the same kind of
visualization as the data
is a really nice way of qualitatively
comparing them and see what matches up
and what doesn't
so if i drew out to m87 in my spaceship
and parked at a respectable distance
would i see anything like what that
picture looks like
i no you wouldn't see that swirly
picture i mean you you know
you see some pretty dramatic things i
think but
and you might even see some of the
effects of the magnetic field because
just like if you think about those
beautiful pictures that you get of the
sun where you see the plasma
flowing along the magnetic field lines
of the sun you could well be seeing
those kind of phenomena where the plasma
around the black hole is
flowing along the magnetic fields and
really picking them out so you could
actually
effectively see the magnetic field lines
but they wouldn't look i don't think
quite like those visualizations
and lastly professor you indicated that
this
data is the original data they used
before just analyzed in a new way
why does it take so long it's because
it's a so
you really got to check every possible
there are lots of possible systematic
things that can creep in there are lots
of things that can mess up your data
so they spend a lot of time calibrating
the data making sure they really
understood the data
making sure there wasn't anything left
in the data that was not associated you
know that was not astrophysical but was
to do with their telescopes
so there's a huge amount of processing
and then actually computationally you
know just actually
analyzing the data producing these maps
doing all the simulations
it's a huge amount of work so it's taken
more or less all this time just to get
from the point of producing that first
image
and even in that first image they knew
there was polarization information there
but to go from that to actually being
able to do something quantitative saying
this is how big the polarization
is this is how it's oriented it's a
massive work which is why it's taking
quite a while to get here
i know i ask you this all the time but
there's a great big supermassive black
hole presumably
right on our doorstep at the center of
our own milky way
can we just not get a good enough look
at it
in fact so there's there is i mean it's
much smaller than one in the middle
of m87 it's in you know in the millions
of solar masses rather than the billions
of solar masses but you know it's a
thousand times closer
so actually the scale of things is the
same interestingly
it's i think i mean and they've been
trying to produce a picture of the
of the black hole in the middle of the
milky way as well with the the event
horizon telescope
um the reason why it's difficult is this
faraday rotation thing that actually the
the maybe the things emitting you know
beautifully polarized
light around from around the black hole
but actually between
us and the center of the galaxy there's
a whole bunch of magnetic fields
associated with the galaxy
which really messes up the uh the radio
emission plus this interstellar medium
which causes scintillations
it's just a lot harder to look at our
own uh
black hole in the middle of our own
galaxy because we're peering through all
the things between us and the center of
the galaxy
we should just mess up the picture
whereas m87 is well out of the plane of
the galaxy so there's really not much us
between us and m87 and so we get a much
clearer view of something which is sort
of the same size at least in terms of
angle
which makes it a much easier thing to
look at
the black hole onto what we call the
accretion disk which is sort of the
bathtub of water that's trying to spiral
in
you've almost merged the two plug holes
so you've made the plug hole bigger
so not only have you grown the black
hole in that way you've then almost made
it easier for it to
create more material right because
you've made it so that it has a bigger
gravitational
pull